este fue el momento exacto de la
explosión en el puerto de beirut
el 4 de agosto de 2020 más de 200
personas murieron y siete mil resultaron
heridas en la capital y vanessa dentro
de los 200 fallecidos esta alexandra sus
padres por na guiar y tracy nayar
aprendieron a convivir con la tristeza
pero la rabia y la angustia por la falta
de justicia no los deja tranquilos
siempre decimos que vamos a luchar por
la justicia lo haremos hasta el día que
nos muramos esta es nuestra nueva vida
una vida de lucha de justicia de verdad
la vida del 4 de agosto
perdemos toda esperanza de ver el
ejercicio de la justicia en el líbano no
haremos ningún esfuerzo por la justicia
libanesa excepto para demostrar que la
justicia ha fallado
paul y tracy se unan al llamado de
algunas víctimas de la explosión que
piden al consejo de derechos humanos de
la onu enviar una misión de
investigación para esclarecer la
responsabilidad del estado y de
políticos libaneses la explosión no
nuclear más grande de la historia se
debió a la detonación de dos mil 750
toneladas de nitrato de amonio
almacenadas en el puerto de beirut
durante y seis años el inadecuado
almacenamiento de este compuesto químico
potencialmente explosivo se debió a la
negligencia y corrupción del gobierno
libanés según una investigación inicial
de human rights watch emergen calaf
diputado libanés confía en la justicia
no deben perder la fe en el sistema
judicial libanés deben seguir
presionando a los políticos para que se
abstengan de bloquear el caso y los
políticos implicados en la explosión en
el puerto acusados de negligencia y
corrupción han presentado más de 25
solicitudes para destituir al juez
encargado para evitar lo que ha
paralizado las investigaciones desde
hace un año